a man has crawled his way back into
theaters and he's ready to live ten
times his own weight at the box office
so raise your antennae because you know
what let's just get right to the
references in Easter eggs
the new film opens with Scott and his
daughter Cassie playing inside an
elaborate maze but if you watch closely
they're actually recreating some of the
heist from the first film
Cassie holds up a fake eye for a retinal
scan just like how Scott made a fake
thumbprint to get in a hank pym vault
imitation yarn laser stand-in for the
Laser grid that Scott had to get through
in order to steal the yellowjacket suit
which was held in that's right an
inaccessible vault they say write what
you know who knew this was also true for
elaborate cardboard playsets Cassie also
gives Scott a trophy that reads world's
greatest grandma this is also a callback
specifically to Scott and Cassie's game
of giving one another terrible gifts
remember when he buttered that ugly
plush bunny for her birthday party later
Louise tries to pump himself up into
taking ownership of ex-con his new
security company repeating the mantra on
the boss I'm the boss I'm the boss to
himself he clearly picked this up from
Scott who we heard saying the same
refrain while preparing to go big in
Captain America Civil War ex-con itself
is sort of a play on the original Marvel
Comics as well Scott Lang once founded
his own security firm called ant-man
security solutions in South Beach Miami
along with former rival Maxwell Markham
aka Grizzly Walton Goggins plays the
greedy arms dealer Sonny birch in the
movie who's lifted from the pages of
ant-man comics he's the former CEO of
Kross technologies the company Darrin
cross was creating out of the old pimp
technologies in ant-man and the comics
Burch also collaborates with Obadiah
Stane who was played by Jeff Bridges in
the first Iron Man movie later Laurence
Fishburne shows up as a former colleague
of Hanks named Bill Foster this is also
a character from the comic books who
used pin style technology to transform
into black Goliath in the movie bill
notes that he and Hank worked together
on project Goliath funnily enough a
deleted scene from Iron Man 2 featured
Tony
dark asking Jarvis about an old project
called Goliath not so surprising
considering that we establish Hank Pym
and Howard Stark collaborated back in
the first ant-man film the same scene
also had Tony name-checked project
Pegasus which we now know was shields
codename for the tesseract but Tony then
asks Jarvis for files relating to
project Exodus which we have not yet
explored in the MCU and which in the
comics involves both Carol Danvers aka
Captain Marvel and a certain fantastic
space expedition involving four
astronauts what but let's get back to
ant-man Hannah John caimans ghost
character also references a villain from
the comics though she's usually an Iron
Man villain and a he in the movie ava
has a very different backstory in origin
that actually works in some additional
Marvel lore we briefly see her father
the bald-headed scientist Elias Starr in
flashbacks and the comic star is
actually the longtime ant-man nemesis
egghead not to be confused with the
Batman villain that's a totally
different egghead of course it wouldn't
be a Marvel movie without a Stan Lee
cameo he's the guy whose car gets shrunk
during the big chase scene who chalks it
up to yet another LSD flashback a joke
to be sure but possibly also a shout-out
to an obscure incident in Marvel history
according to Marvel Comics the untold
story editorial assistant Dennis O'Neil
was once dared to drop a sugar cube of
acid into Stan the man's coffee he
declined and it's probably a good thing
this movie features human size dance and
office buildings that people carry
around like suitcases this guy doesn't
need drugs and because this is the very
first trip back to the MCU post infinity
war a post-credits scene shows us all
the pins and Van dines getting taken out
by Thanos if you stay until the very
very end the credits say ant-man and the
wasp will return but with a question
mark
curse you Thanos
worse yet we leave Scott still stuck in
that pesky quantum realm where time and
space lose all meaning which is a real
bummer because who doesn't love time and
space Janet Van Dyne warned Scott not to
get caught in a time vortex which sounds
bad
but could also relate to a major theory
about time-travel playing a role in the
future of the MCU
I mean access to a realm where time and
space lose all meaning could prove
pretty useful if you were say trying to
reverse a certain finger snap made by a
certain oversized purple guy wearing a
certain magic glove so this is almost
definitely going to come back in Captain
Marvel and Avengers for y'all take notes
another major theory surrounding the
ending of Avengers infinity war is that
after Thanos snapped his fingers instead
of just dying outright our heroes ended
up trapped inside the soul stone in a
sort of soul realm could Scott use the
quantum realm to access the soul realm
and retrieve all those other Avengers
Infinity Ward directors the Russo
brothers have teased that the quantum
realm will have a significant role to
play in the future of the MCU though
there are precious few clues in ant-man
and the wasp itself actual real-world
quantum physicist dr. spero Michael aqus
one of Marvel's consultants on the movie
tease that the quantum realm will give a
better understanding of Carol Danvers
and her place in the MCU also it may be
worth mentioning that the Marvel
Universe has a totally separate
antimatter component called the negative
zone that's pretty visually similar to
the quantum realm and that we visited
before in wait for it Fantastic Four
comics were through the looking-glass
here people by the way Hank Pym slab
from ant-man in the wasp complete with a
tunnel allowing travel another quantum
realm was actually among the largest
single standing sets ever constructed
for an MCU movie
not content to leave it at just marble
references ant-man and the wasp riffs on
a whole bunch of pop-culture hey this is
the marvel comedy franchise so Scott
Lang does what he wants after their
first terrifying encounter with ghosts
Scott's friend Kurt suggests that she
may be the Baba Yaga this is a real
supernatural being from Slavic folklore
and it's not just the ant-man franchise
that has recently made reference to her
in John wick to Peter's store Mayer's
character also compares Keanu Reeves to
the Baba Yaga which he explains is
basically like saying he's the boogeyman
at one point while he's bored and
waiting out his house arrest
Scott watches the classic comedy Animal
House on TV this specific scene features
Donald Sutherland as Professor Dave
Jennings blowing his students minds with
science facts here's some of the
dialogue our whole solar system could be
like one tiny atom in the fingernail of
some other giant being that means one
tiny atom in my fingernail could be one
little tiny universe kind of
foreshadowing the quantum realm where
Scott will soon find himself stuck
possibly for all eternity right but
before all that fun stuff there's time
for a little whale watching the boat
captain credited as captain Daniel
Gubler with three o's is played by
comedian Tim Heidecker of Tim and Eric
Fame the movie ends not including the
post-credits sequences with scott cassie
hope and their shrunken down friends
watching a movie Drive in style on
Scott's laptop the film in question is
1954 stem which featured giant
man-eating ants that threatened to
destroy all of human civilization well
that's it for ant-man and the wasp
Easter eggs and just in time too
because I've got ants in my pants wait
what that one doesn't even make sense
who's writing these look I can spot
Animal House clips it's not that hard
you